NARRATOR: Obama needs
just two Republican
senators to defy their party.
He turns to the veteran leader
of the Senate Democrats.
None of the Republicans who
wanted to do something to help
wanted to be the 60th vote.
So I had to get 61
votes on everything.
And it was very hard.
The only ones I had any
hope of getting-- Specter
from Pennsylvania,
and then I had
the two senators from Maine.
NARRATOR: Maine
Senator Susan Collins,
a Republican Reid
identifies as vulnerable,
is invited to the Oval Office.
SUSAN COLLINS (VOICEOVER):
I was shocked when I walked
in expecting to see
the economic advisers,
other staff taking
notes, and instead, it
was just the President and me.
I told him I thought
the package was too big.
He told me that his economists
were telling him that a smaller
package would not do
the trick and would not
boost the economy sufficiently.
NARRATOR: Senator
Collins agrees to meet
behind closed doors with a
group of 17 other senators.
When senators from
both parties meet
outside the control of the
leadership, it's called a gang.
This gang of 18 came together
with the primary focus
of wanting to reduce the cost
by at least $100 billion.
NARRATOR: Obama reluctantly
agrees to the cuts
because it looks as though
this will buy him the votes
he needs.
But the Republican
leadership leans
hard on Republican
members of the gang of 18.
SUSAN COLLINS (VOICEOVER):
Although we had a number
of Republicans who joined those
first few meetings, gradually,
the numbers diminished greatly.
I didn't know if we
could get this done.
And I told the President that.
I had to wait till
his helicopter landed
to give him the
bad news, saying,
I'm not sure I
can get this done.
I received this phone
call from Harry Reid
to come over to his office.
And I really debated
whether or not to go.
I went into the room, and
the room was already filled
with Democratic leadership.
NARRATOR: Collins from Maine
objects to a $16 billion
program for school construction.
I knew that that would create
huge opposition on my side
of the aisle, because
we'd be redefining
the federal role in education.
And then the conversation
kind of shifted
over to health clinics.
And there was a suggestion
made that we could take some
of those resources and
put them into constructing
community health clinics,
even in the state of Maine.
And she lit up and showed
some real interest.
On this vote, the yeas are 61.
The nays are 36.
3/5 of the senators
duly chosen and sworn
having voted in the affirmative,
the motion is agreed to.